I see our buddy saatvik obligation as a
biological obligation that we are to
care for the earth after all the earth
cared for us and we're like we're like
scabies or something you know I mean it
can't be very much fun for a planet to
have a species on it which is always
extracting petroleum and spreading
plutonium around and dumping junk into
the oceans and the atmosphere just said
you know my god what is this it's a
raging viral infection of some sort and
yet we may be the means to a technology
that would actually then give us a
destiny save history from just being
madness century after century of rape
and pogrom and just you know the horror
that it is I'd like to redeem that
unlike Stefan Daedalus I'd like to
awaken from the nightmare mercy liad
once made a wonderful statement he said
he was comparing our culture to a dying
person and he said in the same way that
a dying person sees their whole history
flashed before their eyes a dying
culture will frantically publish
everything in one last final spasm of
fear every Egyptian text every Tibetan
text every Hopi prophecy everything will
be published published published because
they're looking for answers somewhere it
has to be if the did the Tibetans know
it did the we Toto know it did the inner
wit know it who knows that we've got to
find out and eventually they'll get
around to sing women what about these
psychedelic people we've been jailing
them and hounding them for years they
claim they have an answer
get him get him on the line we'll talk
to anybody at this point bad times lie
ahead things are going to get worse
before they get better but they're going
to get battery
[Music]